de vuelta a las urnas la oposición
venezolana anunció que se presentará a
las elecciones locales y regionales del
21 de noviembre serán sus primeros
comicios como una gran coalición después
de varios años de llamar a la abstención
ya boicotear los últimos procesos
electorales al considerarlos
fraudulentos y aunque estas elecciones
tampoco están exentas de dudas confían
en que su participación ayude a
pavimentar el camino a las
presidenciales
sabemos que esta comisión no será unas
elecciones justas ni convencionales la
dictadura ha impuesto obstáculos graves
que ponen en riesgo la expresión de
cambio del pueblo venezolano se
presentarán a las urnas con la tarjeta
de la mesa de la unidad democrática la
mayor coalición opositora del país que
en 2015 le arrebató la asamblea a los
chavistas por primera vez en 15 años
aunque se inscribió como partido en 2012
en 2018 la justicia la inhabilitó por
doble militancia al estar conformada por
varios partidos en junio de este año el
consejo nacional electoral volvió a
habilitar la des de otra a la de la
oposición el líder juan guaidó insistió
en que no hay garantías para una
elección libre y justa
contra el presidente nicolás maduro el
mandatario felicitó a quienes decidieron
entrar en el proceso es digno de
aplaudir
el gesto político
de participar otra vez en las elecciones
como lo dije puedo decir que hemos
traído al campo electoral a toda la
oposición venezolana el anuncio llega en
medio de una nueva ronda de diálogos en
mexico entre el gobierno de maduro que
busca el levantamiento de sus sanciones
y la oposición que entre otras demandas
busca garantías para unas elecciones
libres y justas